how many I just never count it's like
they just always there like I think I
have like a white a white t-shirt fairy
I just wake up his new t-shirt every day
[Music]
always got to have a big any other
lighter that's not a big it's fake
like it's not fake but it's just like
you know it's just what you like a Bic
is like awful then when you get to know
the clearest lightest that's more of an
Android there's nothing wrong with it
you know it all makes cause but I think
I want to make my class on the iPhone
toothpaste is essential I'd like to arm
a hammer that's my favorite
it tastes like powder and baking so it
tastes good my nexus century was my back
it's the backpack I got this when I was
in Paris I believe long time ago I was
on tour with the weekend I pretty much
take one of these everywhere I go I have
a whole collection of goyard I have like
16 bags this is my favorite one and this
is like my worst condition one its rip
right here but I made it until harness
and its really still the book bag it's
not one of those little replica clothing
ones that make a fake boy this is real
cool
come with us Gus on shocks and a shot
this is a nice blanket that I got not
too long ago it's made by watt project
it's really nice set thousand dollar
blanket if it's nice how about anything
I used this blanket like the Snuggie
with no arms a blanket I have a new
bottle in the car but this is a half
bottle of chance from Chanel just like
my favorites enough I remember when I
was younger I would just use excess
cologne not knowing that it was just
dieldrin I would just spray it
everywhere all over me when I get out
the shower and I thought I was just
Liddy then I moved up and I had the old
spice spray then I moved up and I had
the michael jordan Cologne then I moved
up then I had the Kenneth Cole and I
moved up then I had awkward the gia then
I just kept moving up and moving up and
moving up mostly one cent if it's just
you know a studio day two cents if I go
out to the club four cents if I have
something really special going on I'm
one of those people that think it's
never enough fifth grade sixth grade
seventh grade this was very important
eighth grade too and a little bit of
ninth grade so you'll go to the store in
the morning before you go to school and
when you're going to store you'll get
everything that you need for today and
when you go up there you have to make
sure you have money for a booth steps
because we were younger you always had
the problem of licking your lips and you
always would get that ring around your
lips and that was very disgusting
this right here fixes the ring in four
hours it might not be the greatest but
it works here's our adamant little bites
party kick muffins it's kind of hard to
find them sometimes sometimes it's easy
sometimes they're not
toolboxes now a toolbox aspiring a day
I'm allergic to chocolate
so my friends in the truck they
introduced me to these try it tell me
what it tastes like
exactly this is a size 44 which is
roughly the smallest midsize that they
have at Dolce & Gabbana I'll give you
this right here with some Saint Laurent
jeans and some Rick only shoes with a
hat to the bet you would think that I
would have pulled out something way more
you know flashy but flashy it's a moment
this right here is forever nothing beats
a plain white tee I take my dove
everywhere I go so this is really a
great essential they always get me with
the new formula I just know my mom you
should use this so that's why I just I
don't know it's deodorant I don't want
to think about Vaseline intensive care
Cocco radiant lotion I have dark skin so
this lotion right here it doesn't leave
my skin gray from too much lotion and it
works for me in the heat it's not too
thick on me I don't know what's your
skin type but it makes me you know shine
these are ambush gentle monster they're
really nice
Big Sean and Chris Brown came out with a
song called my last and I remember
around that time I wanted to wear a lot
of teaser hats and a lot of ambush power
chains and I had one ambush pouch and
then I treated two pair of Germans got
wings for because I always had the
Germans guys but I used to be on ambush
website and I just knew I couldn't get
none of it
but I got my one chain and I will wear
it I will wear it everywhere I went
I think that clear wasn't my favorite
because they're straight to the point
right now this is not the fit for the
gentle monsters I think it's very very
very very important dad ambush are you
ambushes Lee
[Music]